Drip, glow, soul, way
Clip, pole, smoke, fade
They want the drip, they want the glow
They want my soul, they want the way
I keep a clip, I keep a pole
Who want the smoke? Who want the fade?
Look, I know you on my bumper
I know you want my thunder
Why the laws wanna take us under?
Why the hell am I in this jungle?
I know you on my bumper
I know you want my thunder
Why the laws wanna take us under?
Why the hell am I in this jungle?
Why the hell the law wanna press me?
A little wrinkle in time
Make you pull the iron out
Find out what I'm 'bout
From the insidе out
Ride out the hideout, playin'
Wе don't strike out
Fly out while we drive out
Ain't no timeouts
We don't cry 'bout
How they try to take us all out
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch
Bounce, crouch, or get slouched
My whole hood devout
And vouch for the poems out of my mouth
My mama told me not to be a harlot
Granny helped me take the wise route
Although I'm itty-bitty, sittin' pretty
If the situation sticky, lights out
But for right now, it's funny how
They want the drip, they want the glow
They want my soul, they want the way
I keep a clip, I keep a pole
Who want the smoke? Who want the fade?
You cannot have it all
What's all the starting for?
Drip, glow, soul, way
Clip, pole, smoke, fade
To God who made me
They want the drip, they want the glow
They want my soul, they want the way
I keep a clip, I keep a pole
Who want the smoke? Who want the fade?
You cannot have it all
What's all the starting for?
Drip, glow
Drip, glow, soul, way
Clip, pole, smoke, fade
I can't feel my feet
I feel incomplete
How can all this be?
My body is me
I can't feel my feet
I feel incomplete
My body is me
Back on my feet
Officer, officer
I swear I ain't really got no out with you
Officer, officer, make me wanna...